LES: So Google TV DevRel
office hours.
And we are--
a bunch of stuff has happened.
Probably the most important is
the 2.1 update went out.
So let me talk a little
bit about that, and--
AUDIENCE: Oh cool.
LES: --then we'll answer
questions.
So the first, in my view,
the most important
thing is HLS works.
So if you're sending media,
it will work.
The other thing is hardware
acceleration turned on.
So in the past, it is not
ever [INAUDIBLE].
There were points during
development it was turned on.
But it's definitely turned
on now, and some
apps are seeing bugs.
Other thing is there's some
other attributes in the
content provider.
You can now set the information
for what cable
provider is there.
And also has the TMS identifier
for each channel.
So that if you license
information from Tribune,
you'll now be able
to get that.
LEON: On that particular point,
has the documentation
been updated on that?
LES: I haven't looked yet.
But I asked for it to be
updated by yesterday.
LEON: OK.
LES: So we hope the
documentation
is going to be updated.
So I haven't seen the
bug come through
saying it's been fixed.
LEON: OK.
And that'll be on your website,
because originally it
was included in the
SDK, right?
LES: Right.
It should be on the website,
and it should be there.
Let's see, what else?
LEON: So sorry, just
back on that point.
So in terms of--
LES: Absolutely.
LEON: --the TMS ID
for each channel.
So that just gives you the
channel information.
That still doesn't give you
information on what's kind of
playing or what the user's
watching, right?
LES: Say it again?
LEON: In terms of the TMS
ID you mentioned--
LES: Yes.
LEON: That's really just--
that's the channel
information.
It doesn't tell you anything
about any programming or what
the user's watching.
LES: That's right.
But with that identifier, you
can license with Tribune and
you get information about
the programming.
LEON: OK.
LES: That's how it
works for now.
The other thing you should know
is that if you set min
SDK to 13, then your app will
only go to the update.
Because this is Honeycomb 3.2,
and the other one is 3.1, and
there are still Logitech
Revues out there
that haven't updated.
AUDIENCE: That's me.
LES: OK.
So that's basically what I
can remember that's new.
MEGA: What's the question?
LES: I was talking about
the 2.1 update.
MEGA: So hardware
acceleration.
LES: Yeah.
Hardware acceleration is now
valid, HLS, and the content
provider, the channel listing
content provider.
AUDIENCE: That rolled
out when?
LES: Monday night at 11:00.
MEGA: The animations are much
smoother now because of
hardware acceleration.
LES: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: Cool.
LES: --check it out.
You'll find a lot of
things go better.
I updated all the M4s
on Tuesday morning,
if you have an M4.
And all the Sony boxes should
be updated by the end of the
day tomorrow.
And Revue is some time
in the future.
LEON: So by that you mean
it could be as long as
it took last time?
LES: I'm not even going
to answer that.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hey, it came
by Christmas.
That wasn't so bad.
LES: It may be as long as last
time, it may be shorter, it
may be longer.
So I've given you all
the possibilities.
But it will come.
LEON: OK.
So yesterday the tweet that
went out made a particular
point about Chrome.
So I'm assuming that it's mostly
about the acceleration.
There isn't anything
else about Chrome
that's improved or better?
LES: I don't know what's
happened with Chrome.
I don't really follow Chrome.
And--
MEGA: I think Shaun will
talk about it.
LES: Yeah.
So Mega will ask Shaun.
By the way, the crew
has gotten bigger.
Joel, who does our QA,
and Fabia and Mega--
MEGA: Hi.
LEON: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Howdy.
LES: All right.
So I guess we've started
the questions.
So ah, Christian is joining
us too with breakfast.
CHRISTIAN: Breakfast of
champions or something.
Breakfast for lunch.
LES: Christian, do you know
anything more about 2.1
besides hardware acceleration,
content provider,
and HLS, and Chrome?
What by Chrome changed?
CHRISTIAN: Well I think not
much about Chrome changed.
It's still the same version.
LES: No, they tweeted
something different.
CHRISTIAN: Did they?
OK, then I am out of the loop.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, we did
see the settings page.
They incorporated--
they cleaned it up, basically,
from what I've noticed in the
[INAUDIBLE] versions of
the stable Chrome.
LES: OK, cool.
All right.
We get more from Shaun
if he pops in.
CHRISTIAN: So the other thing
is did you mention hardware
acceleration?
LES: I did.
The reason everyone in the
room talks about hardware
acceleration, one more
time, is test it.
We're seeing folks who turned it
on hoping for the best and
their apps break.
So it's always important
to check out hardware
acceleration.
But it is showing
some real wins.
So--
LEON: So in terms of this
update, are we going to expect
similar short-term updates
before the big one that was
announced for the
end of the year?
LES: What big one was
announced for
the end of the year?
LEON: So somebody said, and I
think this was at CS, somebody
said that there was a big one
planned for the end of the
year, a major update.
LES: There will be a couple--
there will be some things
before that.
Whether you consider that a huge
update or not, but there
will be some updates.
Beyond that, I won't
speculate.
I would say most of the updates,
there's going to be
some feature updates, but most
things are going to be related
to apps for the short-term, and
also for getting them on
new platforms, bringing
up boxes.
MALE SPEAKER: That would be 2011
is really more about the
new Marvell Flash
ARM platform.
LES: Yeah.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: What about 2012?
LES: So Leon's asked a
bunch of questions.
Let's go ask somebody else.
If I can find my cursor.
Here we are.
There we are.
So let's start with Will.
You were starting to ask about
looking for some goo-- oh,
actually you should just post
that to the question list,
rather than--
WILL: Oh, OK.
LES: --here because only the
people who are actually on the
chat, and so far it is basically
two of them are us,
and Leon and John.
I've invited 10 people.
WILL: Yeah, I know some
other people who said
they wanted to join.
So I hope we get some
more people.
I didn't want to be too
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I don't know if that's
appropriate for this hangout.
But I have a feature list that's
really long right now,
and I could use some
good help.
So if you want to do some
side work, let me know.
LES: Yeah.
There was somebody looking for
it who posted on one of my
links before.
It was Bradley Gogats.
WILL: OK.
I'll look for him.
LES: He's written to me before,
but I don't know him
or his work.
I'm sure that my comment will
get me feedback, however.
WILL: I appreciate that.
LES: OK.
But that's there.
Let's see.
OK.
WILL: I have a question.
LES: Sure.
WILL: This might be just my
stupidity, but in my app, I
cannot put tags or keywords into
the description page on
my app for the market.
Is that something that I'm
just missing, or is there
going to be tags that we're
going to be add soon?
I just put keywords in my
description, which was kind of
clunkey, and I don't know if
that's something that would be
frowned upon.
But I'm trying to get as much
attraction as I can to it.
LES: You know, we reviewed
your app.
And I'm not sure why it hasn't
been featured yet.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] say?
MEGA: Is it [INAUDIBLE]?
LES: Yeah.
MEGA: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: OK. so we're going to
review it again today.
WILL: OK, awesome.
I did some tweaks on the
UI over the weekend.
So hopefully, that's going to
be able to push it over.
LES: Yeah.
It should definitely be
going because it seems
like a great app.
So--
WILL: Excellent.
Thank you very much.
LES: OK.
All right.
I presume just out of the
block that Paul doesn't
actually have any questions.
So John had a whole bunch
of questions.
They were mostly user questions
as I remember.
JOHN: Yeah.
probably so.
I think one of my main questions
is the integration
of YouTube remote, and
the YouTube app.
It was until very recently based
primarily on the old
YouTube Leanback interface.
And they've been kind of taking
some stabs at getting
the tossing of content to and
from the TV to your remote
device a little bit better, but
it's still pretty rough.
And that seems to be a key point
of better integration.
I'm just kind of raising
the flag on that.
There's all sorts of potential
there, and it doesn't seem
like it's getting a
lot of attention.
LES: Yeah.
That kind of stuff, you
should probably--
there's another hangout that
happens every week with the
product management.
JOHN: OK.
LES: And they're the ones to
tell that to, and that would
be Rishi Chandra, or
AK, or any of the
product management folks.
They're the ones to give that
kind of feedback to.
I'm going to just read some
questions I think, and see
what we get just because--
OK.
So Chris is asking a couple
of questions.
So the first is, wants to enable
NDK for Google TV.
Don't hold your breath.
My guess is that it won't
be any time soon.
Part of the reason is that
when we added Chrome, we
changed some of the libraries.
And so we're not in a compatible
environment.
We're working to get that fixed,
but it'll be a bit.
The other thing is when are
we coming to Canada?
And I'm doing an event in Canada
to prepare developers
for Google TV. So if you're
there and you're in Toronto,
look through my stream because
I'm going to start inviting
folks in a little bit.
But there's still room.
And I'm actually doing several
events in Toronto.
But that's the one
we're putting up.
Also, you mentioned YouTube.
We're going to be doing a invite
only event at South by
Southwest. And if you've got
content on YouTube, and you
want to access it from an
Android app, send me a note,
and we'd be happy
to talk to you.
But you've got be at South
by Southwest. That
addresses the Canada.
Chris also says he wants to
learn to be a developer.
So the place to do that is
developers.google.com/tv.
MALE SPEAKER: There is another
one which is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
When will the Google TV add-ons
be available for
Windows or OSX from
[INAUDIBLE]?
So that's unfortunately some
misconception that I've heard
on another forum where people
were saying they can't develop
for Google TV because they don't
have a Linux machine.
And unfortunately, I think this
is because our emulator
does not work on anything
other than Linux.
What I usually say is for
development itself, you just
need a regular machine, Windows
OSX is just fine.
You need the Android SDK.
The Google TV add-on
only really only
gives you the emulator.
If you are developing apps with
the intention of putting
them in market, you really need
a hardware device anyway.
I would like to see the one
application that somebody has
developed that they've never
tested on a real hardware
device and then it actually
worked flawlessly.
So I think for, I want to say,
getting your feet wet, playing
around, the emulator
is a great tool.
Supplementing development, it
gives you a nice way to test
different screen resolutions,
play around, get some quick
feedback, the emulator
is useful.
But for real development, you
need at least one of the
actual hardware devices.
LES: OK.
Let's see.
Will a source be available for
people to start making home
brew versions of Google TV
and standalone boxes?
Surely, that would do wonders
for global proliferation.
Discuss.
That was from Magnus.
OK, so the Google TV
fundamentals are Open Sourced.
The problem is that Google TV
consists of the Android Open
Source project, plus some
private source not Open
Sourceable plus apps.
And so what we're making
available to--
we're in the process of making
some of the apps available to
the OEMs who only want to have
Android-only television sets.
And they will be part of the
standard Android app set that
an OEM can pick up.
Eventually--
that's probably as much as
I can say about that.
You want to take the next
one, Christian?
CHRISTIAN: Sure.
Which one is the next one?
MALE SPEAKER: Ali Nadoff.
CHRISTIAN: Let's see.
One request. It seems that each
week, either through the
comments here or during the
hangout, a number of questions
are raised that you or someone
else in the side
breaks to look into.
Unfortunately, it's
very rare to hear
anything back on those.
Would be possible for you to
take some action items onto
yourself, and your teams first
start with giving some updates
on previous action items?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So basically more of
a report style.
I think if you have some issues
that really need that
sort of tracking, it's best just
to use our forums, or use
Stack Overflow for technical
questions.
The hangout, it's really more
of a, I want to say, an
informal thing.
There is a lot of requests that
we get from developers,
which we raise at the
appropriate times with our
development team.
So for example, when they come
and they prioritize the next
version with which features
should go in, it's good for us
if we can bring real
world examples.
We can say hey, if you enable
feature x, be it overlays on
live TV, or be it things like
NDK, here is the five killer
apps that you will get for it.
So it's not like a immediate.
It's not like OK, next
week we will tell you
when we have NDK.
But it's more like OK, if we
get asked from our team, is
anybody really actually caring
about NDK, or how does NDK
compare to other stuff?
Then we can give them the
feedback, and we say hey, we
really hear this a lot from
developers and it would make a
big difference.
Also, the Google TV issue
tracker launched last week.
MEGA: Yeah, so I wanted to add
that with some of the features
what Chris said are coming to
you, it's better to log them
in the issue tracker and if it's
on [INAUDIBLE], star it.
So the more the number of stars
it has the higher the
priority it is.
LES: Yeah.
Everything at Google works
on voting and feedback.
So this is the issue tracker.
What is the URL for that?
MEGA: code.google.com/
p/googletv-issues.
LES: So that's code.google.com/
So real important.
That's the best way to ask
for features, report a
bug, track a bug.
Let's see.
OK, so I'm going to go to
Leon because he's there.
I've invited, by the way, this
nice person from Google TV
developers, or Google
TV friends.
He hasn't yet shown up.
OK, Leon.
You've just got a couple
more questions.
LEON: Yeah.
And a few more that isn't
in your post.
So regarding the fact that there
isn't really SD storage
on the current devices, are
there any plans on using maybe
USB to compensate for that?
Do you kind of use that as
a place for storing apps?
And kind of moving forward, from
a development point of
view, are the platforms moving
to a point that they will have
SD card slots or increased
storage for apps or not?
LES: Most of the platforms
actually do have
some external storage.
It's sort of simulated out of
the existing format of Fat 32,
so a tiny drive.
You will want to--
you'll get the extra storage.
So your apps can certainly
use it.
As far as putting apps on
it, I have not tried.
So I can't really comment
about that.
LEON: Yeah.
I couldn't figure that out
because it doesn't seem to be
like the phones, where you could
specify use SD storage
for the apps.
I didn't see that anywhere,
at least from a
user point of view.
The point I'm trying to make
is just that it's quite
limited at the moment.
It's like 500 and something
meg to store all the apps,
which puts a limit on
the number of apps.
But also what the apps
themselves can store within
that internal storage.
So if the app wanted to cache
to have some more local
storage, that is quite limited
at this phase.
LES: I thought that it's
different for different OEMs.
LEON: It looked the same
to me, between the
Logitech and the Sony.
They look the same.
So in terms of moving forward,
is that kind of
how it would be?
You're not seeing new platforms
that have SD slots
in it, for example.
LES: Christian?
CHRISTIAN: That's
an OEM question.
So from the boxes that
we have today, no.
I don't know what the plans
are, going forward.
But I could imagine that USB
storage is probably the more
popular choice.
LEON: Yeah, that makes sense.
It's just that it seems the
system isn't set up to kind of
just flip to that or extend the
internal one for the apps.
Is that also an OEM choice?
It's not something that Google
TV can say if there is
something, then the user can
maybe toggle that and say use
that for storage, app storage.
CHRISTIAN: So I don't know
what the plans are.
It's another one of those
features where we can raise it
with the engineering team, but
it has not been very high on
the agenda right now.
LEON: OK.
Thanks.
LES: I'm trying to add Google TV
friends who has questions.
But let's see, Will has a
couple of questions too.
So we can go back to--
oh, and Will even wrote his from
his developer partner.
The other developers or Google
TV can recommend developing
testing on the Android
X86 platform.
If so, is it possible to cut
the TV resolution on an
Android X86 VM under
Virtual Box?
I develop on an actual
device myself.
But that is part of the search
for better emulators.
What I'd like to your partner
to do is write me.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
LES: The fundamental
rule of thumb is--
yeah, write me.
I almost said it.
I'm not going to say it because
I'm publishing these.
WILL: He's watching you right
now, so he'll write to you.
LES: OK.
Cool.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So I actually
had a question for Will.
So Will, you posted that the
market search shows apps which
are not Google TV specific,
before applications that are
Google TV specific
in the market.
I'm not quite sure what you mean
with Google TV specific.
So technically, every app which
does not require touch
screen shows up.
Are you referring to apps which
actually require the
Google TV feature?
WILL: This might be a little bit
outdated, but I know that
within the last couple weeks
I've searched for apps and
they will install.
And then once they start up,
they will require portrait
mode, which is not going to be
supported on the Google TV. So
that's mainly the ones
that I've seen.
The other requirement that you
speak of, I think correctly
blocks them.
But I know that I've installed
portrait-only apps, and then
when I start the app
they don't--
obviously, they're not
going to work.
MALE SPEAKER: So that is
actually one thing that we
have changed in the market
plan for the OTA version.
So the market client will
actually filter out apps which
declare portrait mode.
So there's two ways to require
portrait mode.
One is if you can have it on
the manifest, explicitly
declare, those we
can filter out.
And then there's others
who do it at run time.
Those we still can't filter
out, unfortunately.
But we are trying to limit the
number of apps that show up
that require portrait mode.
WILL: That's some really
good news.
It's frustrating to see an app
that comes up above something
that's specifically written for
Google TV. So I'm glad you
guys are working on it.
LES: OK, Dustin writes,
assuming I
can read this properly.
How do we submit an
app for review?
Just released one
a few days ago.
Any chance to get an example of
how to hook the search API
while watching live TV?
I think most develops would
love to see this.
OK, so let's talk about
both of those.
One is send us your
package address.
A good place to send it
is googletv-android
@googlegroups.com, or if you
have my email address do that.
But I'd much rather it come to
the group email address.
And we'll review it.
And then the other thing Dustin
was asking was the
search API.
So that's best if you actually
join the hangout and clarify
what you're asking, because the
search button is a global
search for Google TV. It works
while you're in a hangout--
or excuse me, it works while
you're watching live TV. It's
global, it works everywhere.
But the user has to enable
your app for search.
So one thing you can do is on
launch, or include a menu item
somewhere that says enable for
search that brings up the
preference pane that
they have to click
to enable that provider.
But they have to do an explicit
action to enable the
search provider.
And I think that's as far as I
can answer questions on this.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Les,
can you restate
that question again.
I'm not sure if I heard it all,
and I'm not sure if I
might have something to add.
LES: OK.
Sure.
This was from Dustin.
Any chance to get an example of
how to hook the search API
while watching live TV. I think
most developers would
love to see this.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Yeah.
I don't think I have
anything yet.
LES: OK.
We do have some search API
sample code, don't we?
MEGA: It's not published.
MALE SPEAKER: It's not
published yet.
MEGA: It was the search
suggestions sample code that I
[INAUDIBLE] as the Android.
LES: OK.
So look at the Android search
provider sample codes.
MEGA: Calls a dictionary
app on the [INAUDIBLE].
LES: Dictionary app.
OK.
Any other live questions?
LEON: Yeah, a few more.
LES: OK.
Let me put you up.
LEON: So I'm going to raise
this again, and I did last
week, but the market app.
The continuous issue there.
In fact, I've got
a problem now.
It's happened to me with
one of the apps.
The NBA app, which is one of
the system installed ones.
It's stuck in a mode on all my
devices where it keeps sending
me a notification there's an
update available, and every
time I try it I actually get the
message that sometimes it
says it's updating, but
it's not really.
Sometimes it's updating
and throwing a
message, an error message.
But it never gets to a point
where it really updates.
So it's stuck in that mode, and
even a reboot of the box
doesn't seem to fix
that at all.
So I'm just raising it again,
because I'm also hearing it
from my users.
They're experiencing market
related issues.
LES: OK.
So the update should have
fixed some of that.
Have you gotten an update--
LEON: No, not yet.
I checked this morning.
It's not on my device yet.
LES: OK.
Feel free to send me an
email with the Mac
address of your device.
Actually, wait till tomorrow.
Wait till Friday.
If you haven't gotten
it by Friday--
yeah.
I can kick things to accelerate
it, but in the
middle of an OTA I don't
want to do that.
So let's wait till Friday
and see what happens.
OK, next.
LEON: Yeah, and the other issue
is about regarding some
of the discussions we've had
about how to categorize or
feature an app like mine.
Have you guys thought about
it more, because of the
multi-device issue?
LES: I will bring
Jen next week.
She is off skiing I think,
which makes it difficult.
But she's the one who
can talk about it.
I think we are planning to
feature able remote.
MALE SPEAKER: Yup.
It's in the works.
Yeah It's in the process.
LES: It's in the process
of getting done.
LEON: So how would
users find it?
Would it just be the
features list?
LES: OK.
What happens when we feature
is there are the Hero apps,
that have a banner
and all that.
LEON: Oh, right at
the top, yeah.
LES: Yeah.
They're right at the top.
I'm not sure that'll make it.
But definitely have one of
those, so that if we decide to
do it, you're able
to be there.
Then there are the seven apps
that are below that.
And then there are 50 or 60
staff picks that you click.
So that will be the next click,
and that's what happens.
And usually from that, that'll
bump your numbers so that when
you go into your categories,
you'll start appearing very
near the front in
the category.
LEON: So you're not thinking
of adding a new category,
because currently, I've got it
in the generic tools category,
which is kind of humongous in
terms of what's in there.
LES: No, at this point, our
hands are kind of tied.
Try to work within everything
that Android has given us.
It is not our place
to influence that.
That's a bigger train than us.
MALE SPEAKER: One thing that Jen
might be able to help you
with is there is a Sony Select,
and I believe there's
something similar on Logitech,
which is sort of the staff
picks for those guys,
for Sony.
Maybe talk with some of their
business development guys, and
point them to your app.
LES: Yeah.
Sony has a developer program.
It may be developers.sony.com.
But if you just Google it.
I'd recommend all of you that
are developing should be a
part of the program.
Let's see.
Google TV friends joined
us, so hi.
AUDIENCE: How's it goin'?
LES: Oh good.
It unmuted you, because I had
muted you when you joined.
AUDIENCE: I just have
a couple questions.
One of them is mostly from users
in my circle of friends,
whatever they are.
In the market, I was just
looking, you have Plenty of
Fish, the dating service,
which is featured or top
three, whatever it is.
That's fine.
But if you scroll through the
social area down at the
bottom, there's two guys, two
developers, FavApps and NetAppers.
In the last two weeks, they've
put in over 75 applications
for like booty calls,
and sexy singles,
find sex in your area.
And a lot of people
don't think--
they think that doesn't belong
on the Google TV. Especially
that many apps in such
a short time.
LES: We'll look into it.
It's in social?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LES: OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that's, like I
said, that's within the last
two weeks, that many
apps showing up.
LES: Yeah.
Obviously we're getting
spammed.
We haven't had to deal
with this yet.
But I can guarantee you,
we will have a
conversation about it today.
And beyond that I can't
tell you much.
But Google's general policy
is one of not censoring.
But I think Android has a
secondary policy around that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's like every day he throws
out a new app with a new
picture on it and just
changes the name.
LES: I will send a note to
somewhere else also.
Something will happen shortly.
MALE SPEAKER: You can also
double-check that they
actually classified it properly
as, whatever, mature
content or whatever
it should be.
LES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And the other question
would be, within the
market, can we get like a--
you have top three
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
can we get a paid section where
a lot of the apps that
you have to buy, they don't show
up in the market unless
you search for them.
There's top three, then
there's the features.
But there's nothing actually to
buy it, to pay for an app.
The one new app that just came
out this week, I believe it
doesn't show up because it costs
$2.99, so you actually
have to search for it in
order to get on a TV.
LES: What's the name
of the app?
AUDIENCE: Twitter for TV or
TV suites for Google TV.
MALE SPEAKER: I think I recently
reviewed that one and
it wasn't supported
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
LES: So it's got issues.
AUDIENCE: That's it for me.
You can mute me again.
I'm just here to listen.
LES: OK. cool.
We're obviously not
filling up today.
So Paul has just IM'd me
a Sony developer link.
It's www.sonydeveloper.com,
which is migrating to
developer.sony.com tonight.
And there's also
developer.sonyericsson.com.
So let's see, you now
know about that.
All right.
Oh, and we still
have it there.
All right, why don't you read
one, Christian, and then we'll
go back to Leon.
CHRISTIAN: I'll let
you read one.
I might answer it.
Actually, I'm on my way
to my next meeting.
LES: OK.
Got it.
All right.
Cool.
And Dustin got it.
OK, any ETA on Adobe
AIR availability?
CHRISTIAN: Don't hold
your breath.
LES: I think that's
pretty much--
CHRISTIAN: I mean I hate to say
never, but it gets pretty
close to it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Basically, Adobe has withdrawn
support for it, and
we have to do it.
There's got to be a
reason to do it.
And really--
Yeah, we'll stay with
Christian's
don't hold your breath.
OK, I think Leon and Will
both have questions.
So let's go with Leon and
then I'll go back to
Will if he's got one.
Thanks, Christian.
CHRISTIAN: Thank you.
Bye guys.
LEON: It's actually related to
the previous question about
how will Google TV handle
parental control?
LES: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The door was closing
as you said it.
LEON: Parental controls
on Google TV, what's
the plan for that?
LES: What kind of controls?
LEON: Parental control.
LES: Parental control, sorry.
I don't know the
answer to that.
MEGA: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: Well TV and movies
very much have
parental controls in it.
You can set settings to only
show certain ratings.
There are apps that do
parental controls.
But I don't know if you
can lock out market.
LEON: Yeah, I was kind of
imagining from a consumer
point of view, they would
probably want to go to one
screen and say these
are the controls,
I want you to enforce.
And then somehow that will
be managed across the
system and the apps.
LES: A reasonable thing, and
I see it on my phone, so we
should eventually get it.
But that would be a good thing
to write as an issue.
LEON: OK.
I'll do that.
LES: All right.
And I'll ask Will if he's got
a question, and then I'll
probably just pop back
between you two.
WILL: Yeah.
My question, I'm not sure if
you can answer it, but it's
about the number of active users
that are using Google
TV. I know--
LES: I actually have
a rap for that.
WILL: All right.
Let's hear it.
LES: So the first answer is
I saw that post and I
was like, oh, OK.
I almost decided to
lead with that.
But it's good that it's now.
OK, so I can't give you
any numbers today.
Even if I had the numbers I'd
have to be reading them just
to make sure they're accurate.
But that's not the question you
really want to be looking
at right now.
Google TV is still in
the hockey stick
portion of its growth.
We've just added three major
OEMs. One of our OEMs has
announced that they are planning
to go international
to double-digit countries.
I don't know if they've
announced the number, so I'm
not going to quote
that either.
But the double-digit number of
country launch, and this year.
So you can, if you'd like to
estimate market size, which
I'd rather didn't show up on
blogs, look at downloads for
apps, including the
installed apps.
WILL: Right.
LES: And that might answer
your numbers.
WILL: Yeah, that's kind of what
this post actually says
too, the pre-installed apps,
look how many times they're
downloaded.
And it just seems like
500,000 to a million.
That seems like such
a huge number to
me, but I don't know.
It's a good number.
LES: OK.
It depends on how you compare
it to phones, because phones
are activating a huge
number a day.
But that said, we're at the
beginning of Google TV's
growth cycle.
When you look at developing,
you want to ask yourself,
where do I see myself
in the market?
And am I better off being a tiny
player in a huge market,
or a bigger player in
a smaller market--
smaller but growing market?
And how do you get
your visibility?
In Google TV, right now is a
great time to get visibility
and build market share.
Ah, Mega has pinged me a
parental control thing.
Perhaps she could put
it into the stream.
MEGA: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: OK.
Yeah.
OK, so anyway, you're
in a growing market.
So you have a chance to become
a significant player in a
growing market, and then use
that to leverage into phones
and tablets.
But that way you get significant
visibility.
Leon managed to get some real
serious visibility a couple
weeks ago when the
nice folks at--
LEON: geek.com.
LES: Which one?
LES: geek.com listed him as one
of the top five apps to
have for Google TV. And he may
or may not have succeeded if
he had been only a phone app.
So it's a developing market.
And that's my rap on that.
WILL: Got it.
LES: OK.
I've got four posts
to my thread, and
we've got nine minutes.
Let's see, we have Mega has
posted to the main thread
about parental controls.
Alexander has posted that Redux
has got between 50,000
and 100,000 downloads.
And he's--
actually, Redux isn't
a bundled app, so
your idea is wrong.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: Yes.
We will probably release an ARM
emulator before the Vizio
Sony launch.
Or whatever Vizio--
yeah, before any of the ARM
boxes launch, Alexander.
All right.
Who's next?
Leon, I guess.
LEON: Yes.
So moving forward from a
developer point of view,
should we be writing for that
Vizio box as kind of the
platform to be concentrating
on from a hardware point of
view, or will there be something
for Marvell that'll
be maybe pre-release or
developer-oriented box?
LES: My guess is that--
I'll find out.
The Vizio will be the box that
comes out, the Marvell box.
Vizio is the manufacturer, or
the distributor for Marvell,
or one of them.
There is going to be a wider
separation of performance, so
we announced two or three system
on a chip vendors.
There's Marvell there
is Media.
OK.
There's another one.
And then LG is doing
their own.
It's like a bat out of hell.
And my suspicion that Samsung
will do something itself.
So Marvell--
so they're all going to be
different graphics performance
and processor performance.
Does that answer
your question?
LEON: Yeah.
I guess related to that is kind
of, would be possible for
us to get our hands on the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] before they
are released to consumers?
LES: I did understand that
part of the question.
That was the part I
was not answering.
LEON: OK, sure.
LES: I don't know the
answer to that.
Right now, I do still have
a whole lot of Revues.
And so I'm trying to
help developers
get started on them.
Yeah.
LEON: OK, thanks.
LES: That's where I'm at.
OK, we've got five minutes.
Any burning questions, or I'll
take the last couple
on the list. OK.
Let's see what we got here.
I think I've answered
everybody's questions.
There is one last
critter here.
Alexander G. is asking
a question I don't
know the answer to.
And it's best to ask this
kind of question when
we're all in the room.
But basically he's saying Qbot,
his app, is failing to
update on Google TV and
some other devices.
Users are getting a bad signed
certificate error.
I'm not sure what happened.
Doesn't the market check the
certs and match when we
upload a new APK.
Ideally.
It's also supposed to check to
make sure that you don't use a
debug certificate when
you upload to market.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
it checks for that.
That's one of the
checks it does.
It wouldn't even allow
you to enable that.
LES: Yeah.
That's what I thought.
So I'm not sure why--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
I've seen this error.
This error is one of the errors
I'm getting with the
apps that have issues
on the market app.
One of many errors.
But this is one I've seen
personally, and then later, it
either resolved or doesn't
resolve, or
goes to another error.
So I just think this is
a market app feature.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
when they are paid apps.
LES: Yeah, these are
all paid apps.
OK, well we should get
it into bug tracker.
MEGA: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: Yeah.
If we could get a log from--
the next time you get it, if
you could an ADB space bug
report, and pipe the output to
a file and send it to any one
of us, that would--
MEGA: [INAUDIBLE] the bug
tracker [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
LES: Yeah.
So ADB space bug report.
OK.
Thank you all for coming.
Tell your friends.
It's nice to have five people on
the hangout, but it's like
we can have 10.
We're broadcasting live.
It's obvious that somebody's
watching the live view.
But anyway, I'd be happier
with a bigger
crowd or more questions.
I hate to invite any of the
engineers when it's only
really two or three people
asking questions.
So I'm going to keep it
with just us for now.
I will do another plug for
my event in Toronto.
Will, I got your note.
Yeah, we'll invite you.
And I'm also going to plug
one more time my South by
Southwest event.
If you're interested you need
to write me, and I will send
you an invite.
Let's see, any others?
Tonight at the GTUG in
Silicon Valley, Paul
Saxton will be talking.
And that should be a
good presentation.
Thank you all.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
LES: Aloha.
We have restored the
server connection.
That's lovely to hear.
I'm not exactly sure--